la fête de gâcher de l'euro en heure des
négociations pour aboutir à un compromis
le néerlandais du zen berck sera
président de la banque centrale
européenne pendant quatre heures puis ce
sera au tour du français après
l'assassinât de yann piat ouverture 2
man du procès de ces assassins présumés
commanditaires pour l'accusation il
s'agit là meurtres exécutés par des
voyous c'est le dossier de notre journal
le colosse qui veillait sur la rade
d'alexandrie sera cette semaine présenté
au public emblème de l'exposition du
petit palais à paris un colosse
magnifiquement conservés la photographie
à l'envers c'est le titre de
l'exposition consacrée au photographe
surréaliste man ray plusieurs centaines
d'oeuvres au grand palais 6000 de cet
américain le plus français de
l'entre-deux-guerres
madame monsieur bonsoir
ouvrons ce journal avec cet après midi
au musée du louvre l'un des plus beaux
musées du monde
ce vol d'un tableau de coraux dérobé
alors que les visiteurs parcourait les
salles du musée
le tableau baptisé le chemin des chèvres
étaient de petite taille susceptibles
d'être cachée dans un sac
les fouilles du public n'ont pas permis
de retrouver cette toile une enquête a
été ouverte
olivier galzi myriam métaoui vent de
pagaille au lourd dans le musée
les caméras ne sont pas les bienvenus à
l'intérieur la police a investi les
lieux à la recherche d'une toile un
tableau de 34 cm sur 49
et personne n'échappera à la fuir
c'est la personne bah oui
vous en dis pourquoi mal informés de la
situation les milliers de visiteurs ont
donc dû subir de longues heures
d'attentes avant de pouvoir sortir
le problème c'est que tout le monde
était parqué sous la pyramide qu'avait
plus d'air les gens fumer alors qu'on
appel d'offres pour les enfants c'était
difficile les enfants les personnes
âgées et l'objet de cette panique
le voici ou plutôt sa reproduction une
oeuvre de camille corot le chemin de
sèvres acquis par le louvre depuis 1902
suspendu à son téléphone le directeur du
musée ne s'explique toujours pas ce qui
s'est passé mais c'est tellement voir
fragile et est mal le tableau oui
combien tous très difficile de vous
répondre
il faudrait payer il a été prêté à
l'exposition coraux qui a eu lieu
aux états-unis au canada récemment donc
il faudra regarder la feuille
d'assurance pour voir un peu à quel prix
ils avaient été assurées à ce moment là
l'enquète a été confiée à la brigade de
répression du banditisme
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'un
tableau est volée au louvre la dernière
oeuvre disparu en janvier 95 n'a
toujours pas été retrouvé à bruxelles le
sommet des 15 aurait pu tourner court
plus de onze heures de négociations pour
finalement aboutir à un compromis sur la
présidence de la banque centrale
européenne la france en faisaient une
question de principe
plus qu'un simple incident de parcours
l'europe aurait pu renouer avec ses
vieux démons ceux de la désunion
jean-paul chapelle
frédéric de la rue la photo de famille
tant attendu il est un peu plus de
minuit
les quinze chefs d'état et de
gouvernement post enfin pour l'histoire
la monnaie unique est lancée
officiellement et après plus de onze
heures de marchandage un compromis est
trouvé sur la banque centrale européenne
son premier président sera le hollandais
vîmes du thunder
il est nommé théoriquement pour huit ans
mais il démissionnera dans quatre ans en
2002 il est venu l'annoncer
officiellement devant les quinze une
bien arrangeante retraite anticipée que
tout le monde feint de croire spontané
il ne souhaitait pas pour des raisons
personnelles assumer son mandat jusqu'à
son terme
on ne rit pas
là aucune raison la raison est simple
laisser la place en 2002 à jean claude
trichet l'actuel gouverneur de la banque
de france serait alors nommés pour huit
ans effectif à la tête de la banque
centrale l'europe sauve les apparences
il n'y a plus deux candidats rivaux
mais un président et son successeur pour
preuve cette longue poignée de main
toujours aussi spontanée ce compromis
conclu finalement par les chefs de
gouvernement de l'union européenne a été
sévèrement condamnée aujourd'hui en
allemagne malgré les tentatives du
chancelier helmut kohl pour le défendre
pour mieux comprendre l'enjeu de cette
présidence de la future banque centrale
avec à la tête
le néerlandais duesenberg pendant quatre
ans puis le français jean claude trichet
les explications de pascal golomer c'est
ici à francfort en allemagne que siègera
la banque centrale européenne la bce à
partir du 1er juillet prochain avec une
mission écrite en toutes lettres dans le
traité de maastricht mener la politique
monétaire de l'europe et un objectif
maintenir la stabilité des prix en toute
indépendance
comment en augmentant ou en baissant les
taux d'intérêt selon la situation
économique
une mission qu'a su remplir pendant plus
de 15 ans vit mme den berg à la tête de
la banque centrale des pays-bas hui
l'ancien ministre socialiste s'est
converti à la fin des années 70 à la
rigueur monétaire à la monnaie forte
ce qui lui vaut le soutien sans faille
des gouverneurs des banques centrales
européennes
l'allemand hans dit mayer et le web part
si jacques chirac et le gouvernement ont
soutenu jusqu'au bout la candidature de
jean claude trichet
par ailleurs défenseur lui aussi d'une
monnaie forte c'est bien pour prouver à
l'opinion française et européenne que
tout ne se décidera pas à francfort une
fois l'euro en circulation mais le
compromis de la nuit dernière n'a faibli
t-il pas la banque européenne avant même
sa naissance son indépendance est elle
déjà remise en cause ce sont les marchés
financiers qui jugeront dès demain matin
en spéculant à la hausse ou à la baisse
sur les monnaies européennes
en attendant l'euro
et puis il y à quelques instants jacques
chirac chez nos confrères de tf1 est
revenu sur cet accord historique
je vous propose de l'écouter ne croyez
pas que je veuille - il l'europe qu'ils
souhaitent
jean de société anonyme en pilotage
automatique pas du tout ce que je veux c
est une europe et ce que nous faisons
c'est une rampe des volontés organisé
volonté des états et volonté des
citoyens
il vous savez ce n'est rien d'autre que
l'europe peuvent être imaginées au
départ le général de gaulle le général
de gaulle alors qu'on avait abandonné
l'idée du traité dans la dite ils font
construire l'europe
il a appliqué le prix des dram
deuxièmement il a dit il faut faire
l'europe des états j'ai donc par le
single rope fédéral et enfin il a dit il
faut faire l'europe de l'atlantique à
l'oural c'est à dire il faut une europe
européenne
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on constate la
france mènera pas à pas et on continue
pire encore à faire on a une remplissent
élargie à l'europe n'est pas le seul à
l'oural
enfin ce sera européenne et on a une
europe des états il n'y a plus de
discussions oiseuses sur la nature de
l'europe demain seront placardées des
affiches destinées à promouvoir l'euro
après le sommet de bruxelles voici donc
cette campagne d'information et de
publicité avec sur le côté pile ce
message nous serons plus forts et sur le
côté face la philosophie de la monnaie
unique pour les français à savoir nous
allons changer d'avenir tout en restant
nous-mêmes
loin des sommets l'europe devient petit
à petit une réalité chez nous ainsi la
ville de perpignan a choisi de déléguer
la gestion de ces bus à un groupe
espagnol
c'est la première fois en france qu'un
service public est confiée à une société
étrangère reportage nous lamberton parce
qu'elle pense
l'espagne n'est plus à la porte de
perpignan l'espagne est à perpignan la
ville va confier à partir du mois de
juillet la gestion de ces bus à un
groupe basé à alicante et à madrid
c'est le résultat d'un appel d'offres
lancé par la commune il ya dix mois
mais c'est la première fois en france
qu'un service public est confiée à une
société étrangère ce qui peut être
important de dire c'est que l'europe se
met en marche et que ce qui se passe à
perpignan ne fais que mon avis nous
rappeler que dans les années qui
viennent y voyant une énorme compétition
sur tout ce qui est services urbains et
c'est une bonne chose
le groupe espagnol était le seul
candidat étranger sur les trois en lice
et même s'il était le mieux placé
il n'en revient toujours pas d'avoir
soufflé le marché au nez à la barbe des
français ça ouvre des perspectives pour
nous mêmes pour nous pour nos
entreprises les deux groupes pour
laquelle je travaille et pour d'autres
groupes espagnols qui s'aperçoivent que
le marché français n'est pas totalement
fermée et qu'il ya là bas du négoce à
faire pour emporter le morceau les
espagnols ne sont pas venus les mains
vides
leur offre était la plus intéressante
tant sur le plan financier que
technologique
la nouvelle compagnie sera française et
pour séduire les salariés il s'engage à
faire des transports perpignanais une
vitrine sociale favorable à l'arrivée le
premier car dès le départ il nous a
garanti nous accorde appropriez vous la
promotion interne l'embauché de toucher
intérimaire que nous traînons depuis
désolé raisonner sans jamais pouvoir les
embauches et que lens est réalisée pour
ainsi dire au 1er juillet le coup est
rude pour la société française via gti
qui gérait les bus perpignanais depuis
plus de 30 ans hasard du calendrier au
moment où elles étaient recalés à
perpignan via gti décroché le marché des
transports d'une ville espagnole
de quoi consoler tout ce que l'europe
prendrait chagrin après plus de cinq
mois de détention préventive christine
deviers-joncour été remises en liberté
lien mois dans une interview aujourd'hui
à canal+
l'ami de roland dumas affirme que le
président du conseil constitutionnel n'a
rien à voir dans la sphère de la vente
des frégates de taïwan
arnaud boutet de cette femme on
connaissait surtout cette image
christine deviers-joncour aux côtés de
roland dumas
aujourd'hui elle a choisi de parler
notamment pour défendre son ami l'ancien
ministre dans la sphère de la vente des
frégates à taïwan où est tous touchés en
dessous de ma part je dire tout ça c'est
un peu comme dirait shakespeare beaucoup
de bruit pour rien à rien pour ça c'est
pour rien je dis n'a pas touché ni
feront pas même une paire de chaussures
christine deviers-joncour confirme que
roland dumas a bien rembourser le fameux
cadeau ces chaussures qu'elle a achetée
11 mille francs avec la carte de crédit
des elfes
mercredi l'ancien ministre a été mise en
examen pour complicité et recel d'abus
de biens sociaux
cela concerne le versement de 8 millions
de francs sur son compte bancaire qui
pourrait provenir des commissions
quelques percées à christine deviers
joncour et cela malgré le refus de
roland dumas de vendre des frégates à
taïwan et c'est vrai qu'à la fin ça
s'est débloqué par l'elysée par par
matignon et c'est vrai que qu'à la fin
mais c'est dumas a levé son veto
ça n'a rien à voir et monsieur
sillonnant pour pousser m'avait dit
qu'effectivement il y aurait une
commission de 45 millions pour moi mais
je veux dire s'ils ont même parlé des
millions comme vous vous parlez
200 francs il ya le plus de mentions
nécessaires
alfred sirvin l'ancien numéro de delphes
qu'elle présente comme autoritaire et
colérique
ils se cachent actuellement en sus
christine deviers-joncour se défend en
rappelant qu'elle n'a jamais pris la
fuite à toulon pour le deuxième tour de
la législative partielle le duel
opposant les pousses du maire front
national sandrine le chevalier la
socialiste d'être casanova s'est joué
autour de la mobilisation des électeurs
avec une abstention record de 55% au
premier tour sandrine le chevalier était
arrivé en tête la semaine dernière avec
39 points 55% des voix je vous propose
maintenant de rejoindre à toulon michaël
darmon a t'on les premières tendances
les premiers résultats
eh bien bon soir à béatrice cette
élection pourrait ce soir bien réserver
une surprise parce que pour l'instant
selon des chiffres émanant de la
préfecture du var sur huit mille
bulletins dépouillés
c'est odette casanova la candidate de la
gauche plurielle qui obtient 51 60 % des
voix alors si cette tendance devait se
confirmer au cours de la soirée et bien
sandrine chevalier candidat du front
national serait battu au d'être casanova
serait donc députés à l'assemblée
nationale une surprise puisque
effectivement ce duel s'est joué sur une
circonscription très ancré à droite mais
l'on sait que la défaite de la droite la
semaine dernière sans consigne de vote
pour le deuxième tour et la mobilisation
accrue que l'on a remarqué cette pour
cette journée de vote a certainement
joué donc en faveur donc peut-être une
surprise effectivement avec l'élection
de dettes que rénova à l'assemblée
nationale merci michael darmon
quatre ans après l'assassinât de yann
piat souffrent de mal le procès de ces
assassins présumés sept accusés
présentés comme le commanditaires et les
exécutants de la députée dans le box des
assises du var pour un procès sous haute
sécurité
l'accusation en s'en tient à la thèse
d'un meurtre commis par des petits
voyous inspiré par un patron de bar le
dossier agnès vahramian bruno gibert
tout
16 juin 94 quatre mois après la mort de
yann piat toulon découvre le visage de
ces assassins présumés
lucien ferri 22 ans il avoue très vite
avoir tiré sur le député du var puis se
rétracte pour nier jusqu'à aujourd'hui
ce qu'on lui reproche
vous voyez mon petit-fils curé puis une
femme tiré sur une femme c'est
impossible c'est pas lui qui a fait ça
marco di caro 21 ans il reconnaît et a
toujours maintenu avoir conduit la moto
du crime
au mont des oiseaux pour lui c'était
pour aider cette personne s'était pas
pour la suède l'ordre de tuer serait
venue de cet homme gérard finale 49 ans
patron du bar le macama désigné par
marco di caro il est le commanditaire
présumé de cette affaire il m'a toujours
dit qu'il était innocent qu'il n'avait
rien à voir dans cette histoire que
c'était un coup fourré qui se demande
comment ça se fait après quatre ans
d'instruction le juge on l'a on est
convaincu le mobile n'est pas politique
pour lui il s'agit d'une affaire de
banditisme et de milieux au centre de
l'accusation marco di caro le repenti de
la bande du macama le soir du crime dit
il j'ai bien conduit la moto mais c'est
lucien ferri le passager qui a tiré sur
yann piat tiré sur ordres de gérard
finale
pour di caro le patron du macama voulait
venger la mort de jean louis fargette
son ami le parrain du var exilé et tu es
en italien non plus tôt selon dit car au
final tenait yann piat pour responsable
de ce meurtre mais des commanditaires
dit car on en a cité d'autres dont un
homme politique local
il a tout schuss
moi je suis un exécutant il y avoue de
sud - certaines personnes il a dit à une
piste politique personne ne l'a cru
personne ne le croit personne ne le
froid car c'est sans preuve que marco di
caro cite le nom de joseph cerciat
adversaires politiques de pia mis hors
de cause après 48 heures de garde a lieu
toute la commandite présumé repose donc
sur gérard finale
pour l'accusation c'est un patron de bar
ambitieux prête à tout pour régner sur
le port gêné par la candidature de pia à
la mairie la police le soupçonne de se
livrer aux raquettes avec une
association de commerçants qui l'a créé
ou encore d'avoir commandité le meurtre
d'autres patrons de bars mais pour sa
femme
le personnage de gérard finale son mari
a été entièrement reconstruit moi ça
fait trente trois ans que je suis mariée
avec mon mari je pense que si ça avait
été un homme terrible je ferai part
était déjà hélas eu le décès dans le
camp correctement ils sont éduqués sont
tout sauf l'île sont équilibrés donc
quand on présente tout votre mari comme
quelqu'un du milieu comme quelqu'un qui
voulait avoir la main sur les affaires
se comprend pas tout ça il n'a jamais
fait la politique d'un âge il n'a jamais
rien fait en art connaît pas cette dame
est ma foi du but en blanc comme ça il
va la tuer de la facture
lucien ferri le tireur présumé en
sait-il plus sur le commanditaire en
mars 95 le jeune homme a refusé de
participer à une reconstitution karimi
tout en bloc et selon son avocat ce
procès ne l'intéressent pas lucia ferry
n'aurait rien a révélé me souviens le
premier jour lorsque je les ai
rencontrés je ne connaissais pas au
préalable il m'a dit vous savez m d'une
prise on en sort d'un cimetière on n'en
sort jamais je crois que c'est une
affaire qui présente des cloisonnements
tels que il ya plusieurs strates et ne
sais pas ce qui s'est passé de toute
façon au lieu et aux étages supérieurs
quel intérêt la mort de yann piat tel
service gérard finale est il l'homme
décrit par l'accusation le mobile est il
crédible le doute va peser pendant ces
six semaines de procès dans le box ce
sera chacun sa version chacun pour soi
pour éviter la perpétuité
en alsace les violents orages qui se
sont abattus vendredi à l'ouest de
strasbourg pour provoquer de sérieux
dommages aux lumières plus de 150
hectares consacré la culture du houblon
ont été touchés par la grêle
un coup dur pour les producteurs car 20%
de la surface cultivée du houblon est
abîmée c'est demain que lionel jospin
devrait inaugurer à nouméa en nouvelle
calédonie le centre culturel jean marie
tjibaou neuf ans après l'assassinât du
leader indépendantiste
ce musée vivant de la culture kanak
devrait servir de passerelle entre les
communautés de l'île
reportage benoît duquesne de nick merlin
c'est le résultat le plus spectaculaire
des accords de matignon
un centre culturel flamboyant au coeur
même de nouméa
comme l'avait souhaité jean marie
tjibaou une structure étonnant pour
symboliser les cases d'une tribu un
endroit mystérieux dont marie-claude
tjibaou à surveiller chaque réalisation
comme si elle voulait s'assurer que le
rêve de son mari n'était pas dévoyé
tibaous lorsqu'elle a négocié sa dans le
cadre des accords s'est établie
un équilibre quand vous venez dans la
ville même si on est sur un père qu'elle
n'a que ça ne se voit pas un niveau de
l' architecture bon ça ne va pas comme
les visites uniques qui existent encore
mais ça va contribuer en tous les cas à
inscrire d'une manière résolument
définitive identité qu'un acte de ce
pays
l'identité kanak fait de parole de
symboles de coutume pour la saisir ou du
moins l'approché il fallait trouver un
architecte ce sera renzo piano
l'auteur de beaubourg pour y parvenir
piano va d'abord écouté s'imprégner
pendant des jours de cette culture
savait des chefs kanak à paroles est
important venez venez les paroles c'est
des choses pour pas gaspiller jamais
gaspiller sa parole je me suis donné
pendant toute cette matinée là j'ai pas
un homme qui a su m'écouter et cherchent
ils à 18 heures il est capable de lire
mais voilà la production de ta parole
voilà quand je vois ça et il a su
démontrer ce qu'il appelle lui une
société de nos égouts mais c'est la
société kanak est en pleine mutation
comme ça mais aussi la société
calédonienne ce pays est en pleine
mutation
une mutation que jean marie tjibaou
voulait est intelligente même s'il
fallait du temps pour que le terme de
kanak ne fasse plus rire pour que cette
culture soient reconnus et pour que les
esprits évoluent le délai qu'ils
s'étaient accordés était de 10 ans
certains le lui reprocher sans doute en
est il mort
pourtant ce délai aujourd'hui paraissait
bien raisonnable il est mort parce qu'il
a signé dix ans avec irene est né là on
rajoute 20 ans j'espère que ça ce qu'on
arrivera tous au bout d'essai attend que
qu'il n'en ait pas de kit en manquant ce
n'est pas un musée que j'ai construit à
di renzo piano c'est la maison de la
parole une maison que beaucoup ici
espère ouverte à tous journée
internationale de la liberté de la
presse avec en 97 26 journalistes tués
dans le monde c'est moi que les années
précédentes
reste que les violations à la liberté
d'informer sont multiples et qu'en ce
moment même pour avoir fait leur métier
de nombreux journalistes sont derrière
les barreaux jérôme bonnet
une pluie de tracts sur le premier
ministre chinois en visite à paris
les fauteurs de troubles sont des
militants de reporters sans frontières
réclamant la libération de la
journaliste gaouyous la chine fait
partie des pays en rouge sur le
planisphère où la liberté de la presse
reste un rêve rédactrice en chef de
l'hebdomadaire économique
gao yu fut arrêté à l'aube du massacre
qui mit fin au mouvement pour la
démocratie
ces derniers mois encore une voiture
banalisée de la police stationné devant
sa maison
gao yu est incarcéré dans cette prison
de yann ching elle partage sa cellule
avec des prisonniers de droit commun et
souffre d'une grave maladie cardiaque
sans recevoir les soins nécessaires
au cameroun la santé du président dia
est un sujet tabou qui a conduit le
rédacteur en chef du journal le messager
en prison son délit avoir fait état d'un
possible malaise cardiaque de paul biya
avant son arrestation déjà pius njawé
vivait dans la peur je ferai l'objet de
menaces de mort depuis plusieurs
semaines de la part des éléments de la
brigade antigang voilà qui je suppose
exécuter des instructions venues de très
loin
son journal est en contact avec reporter
sans frontières qui vient d'écrire une
lettre à jacques chirac dans deux jours
jacques chirac le président de la
république reçoit son homologue
camerounais monsieur biya il faut qu'ils
me disent il faut le libérer
pius njawé comme pius incarcéré ici et
gao yu ils sont 93 journalistes de par
le monde qui suivent l'évolution de leur
pays à travers les barreaux d'une prison
en thaïlande des réfugiés anciens
combattants khmers rouges et des
villageois arrivent par milliers du
cambodge dans des camps installés à la
frontière se déplaçant par tous les
moyens possibles des familles entières
venues du bastion khmer rouge tombée
récemment aux mains de l'armée
cambodgienne après la mort de polpot à
la mi-avril le dernier carré des
combattants khmers rouges semblent se
disculper l'armée algérienne aurait tué
23 membres d'un commando islamique lors
d'une opération dans le
du pays c'est ce qu'a rapporté
aujourd'hui à quotidien algérien il
s'agirait de personnes travaillant dans
un atelier clandestin fabriquant des
explosifs commando qui appartiendrait
touché il ya après ces jours de vol la
navette spatiale columbia atterri tout à
l'heure à cap canaveral en floride sa
mission devait conduire les sept
astronautes à une série d'expériences
pour mieux comprendre le fonctionnement
du système nerveux en l'absence de
gravité
de nombreux animaux poisson cricket ou
souris faisait partie du voyage
il semblerait que les rats n'est pas
survécu un colosse pour l'éternité il
veillait au pied du phare d'alexandrie
il y à quelques millénaires découvert en
95 en quatre morceaux il a été
complètement restructuré as a réuni de
chevreuse et sera dès mardi
exposé devant le petit palais à paris
emblème grandiose de l'exposition
consacrée à la gloire d'alexandrie
gérard dalmas bernie mériaux il y à 2300
ans de l'aimer 2 avec sa soeur et femmes
arsinoé était sentinelles du phare
d'alexandrie qu'il avait construit
quelques tremblements de terre plus tard
la septième merveille du monde s'est
écroulé dans la rate
mais peu à peu les archéologues français
on retrouve le poste dont le fameux
colosse sont quatre morceaux par moins
de 10 mètres de fond 1995
l'impressionnant personnage de la
planète pharaoniques se balance au
dessus des vagues à la surface d'un
autre temps le nôtre
90 cette étude analyse numérique pousse
et 700000 point laser de mesures 81,18
le colosse en khiter en constituer à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse découleront de
métal spéciale lui greffe une colonne
vertébrale dans la chair de granit rose
il faut remettre debout ce titans qui
semblait brisées à jamais aucun rejet
la statue de 10 mètres bien supporté
l'opération il est vrai conforté par ce
corset d'acier au cas où le colosse
ready pieds d'argile 45 jours de travail
acharné remise en cause de certaines
techniques envisagées bonnes et
mauvaises surprises
exc les soigneurs toute la famille de
l'atelier coignard a pas eu vraiment de
moments de doute il ya eu des moments de
grandes difficultés parce que nous ne
disposions pas de suffisamment de temps
pour me étudier tous les problèmes
donc ça a été difficile par le fait que
nous disposions peu de temps les 24
tonnes du colosse ont été ballottés au
moins six siècles dans l'eau de mer
cette restauration financé par la ville
de paris et est donc hors du commun
le coordonnateur en ingénierie
culturelle a donc scruter cette délicate
restauration qu'elle est l'alliance
d'une expérience celle des restaurateurs
qui voient depuis des années sur ceux
qui prônent de restauration dont est
également l'apport de techniques
nouvelles
désormais alliance inévitable du
savoir-faire classique avec l'étude à
l'ordinateur
surtout pour la restauration monumentale
du haut de ses dix mètres devant le
petit palais jusqu'au 26 juillet tollé
mais deux va pouvoir replacer son regard
sur l'éternité
il y à tout juste 30 ans jour pour jour
démarré dans la rue le mouvement de mai
68 ce jour là le premier pavé devenu
l'emblème de ces événements daniel
wolfromm mai 68 commence par un meeting
raté une centaine d'étudiants seulement
présents à cette réunion convoquée pour
protester à la sorbonne contre la
fermeture récente de la faculté de
nanterre
les choses s'éternise ce 3 mai en début
d'après-midi quand brusquement par
crainte d'incidents avec des militants
d'extrême droite le recteur roche fait
fermé à son tour la faculté parisienne
l'évacuation s'est effectué sans
encombre mais la police commettent une
erreur totale d'appréciation pour
vérifier leur identité les étudiants
sont carrément embarqués au commissariat
dans des paniers à salade
à l'extérieur on vient aux nouvelles et
tout se sait rapidement la police est
dans la sorbonne un lieu protégé en
principe depuis le moyen-âge par une
franchise universitaire la résistance
s'organise avec les premières barricades
venu sur place sans directives précises
presque sans encadrement croyant avoir
affaire à un simple monôme les policiers
parisiens frappe sans discernement mais
surprise les premiers pas des vols il
est près de 18 heures mai 68 peut alors
commencer
depuis vendredi matin une gigantesque
rave party en plein air rassemble
plusieurs milliers de jeunes en
seine-et-marne
un important dispositif de la
gendarmerie avec l appui des
hélicoptères ont surveillé sans
discontinuer ce rassemblement quelques
irréductibles pourrait poursuivre cette
fête de la techno jusqu'à demain au
moins un reportage laurent le job
philippe rey oignies durant les
cinquante sono de la plus grosse res
parti de france ont diffusé de la
musique techno trois nuits durant
quelques quinze mille jeunes venus de
toute l'europe font danser dans ce champ
père d'une petite commune de seine et
marne
ben phu
un village d'ordinaire assez calme et
qui selon la formule consacrée n'avais
jamais vu ça avant
il faut il faut quand même pendant
quatre jours et steve il y ait enfin ils
dorment peut-être mais pas qu'on saute
ils demandent peut en effet et aux
abords de la rave une trentaine de
gendarmes avertit un peu tard sont bien
obligés de gérer une manifestation
pourtant non autorisée à l'intérieur on
se réveille dans la boue et en musique
médecins du monde fait son travail de
prévention sur l'ecstasy en trois jours
de personnes ont dû être évacuées pour
consommation abusive de la boue de la
musique un soupçon de stupéfiants les
rêveurs veulent croire qu'il s'agit là
d'un nouveau woodstock on n'est pas des
jeunes qui sont là sont entendus tout ce
qui donne et risquent ils ont des idées
y en a pas mal ya beaucoup d'ingrédients
et au bon on n'est pas entendu parce
qu'on dérange quelque part pour la paix
contre la répression dont ils s'estiment
notamment victimes les plus résistants
des rêveurs de pamfou danseront une
dernière fois cette nuit jusqu'au lever
du jour
retour sur le match événement hier au
stade de france avec la victoire
finalement du paris saint germain qui a
battu lens 2 après une saison en
demi-teinte comment les supporteurs ont
ils vécu cette coupe de france dans les
deux camps vienne la voir ils sont hauts
sur la pelouse mais derrière eux un peu
plus de 15000 massés dans une tribune et
plusieurs milliers encore rassemblés
dans les bars de la ville
avec le vent du nord écoutez les gronder
les supporters de lens
en face ils sont habitués mieux
organisés peut-être mais pas encore
blasé l'objet de l'enjeu entre le psg et
lens
une coupe une ligne de plus peut-être
dans le palmarès d'un joueur mais
surtout une énorme fierté pour des
supporteurs poussée par de bonnes ondes
les lensois attaqué domine d'obèses tir
mais fernandez belle et puis contre le
cours du jeu sérail qui ouvre la marque
qui abat d'un coup de tête des milliers
de cheminots
à la mi-temps le psg mène 1 à 0
malheureux sur comme peut l'être marco
simone et lorsqu'il se retrouve seul
face à un gardien sûr que cette fois 2 0
l'orgueil lensois vient d'en prendre un
coup j'ai moi bah c'est pas possible
béninois il fallait vis pas mes mots
quoi chiner
elle est déçu comme tous les lensois
mais la petite flamme ne s'éteindra pas
avant la fin du match puisque ce mystère
redonne de l'espoir aux gens du nord qui
exulte un moment seulement avant de
pleurer lorsque les parisiens soulèvent
leur cinquième coupe de france dans les
travées de saint denis ou sur les
chaises des cafés la même tristesse la
joie a changé de camp et pourtant on n'a
pas gagné mais on adore quand même
et tandis que les champs elysées sont
pris d'assaut on défile aussi à lens car
il reste l'espoir l'espoir d'être sacré
champion de france samedi prochain
en vendée des coureurs chevronnés se
mesure à la marée montante 4 km dans les
vagues une épreuve originale entre l'île
de noirmoutier le continent olivier piou
michel hiver la mer déjà submergé le
bois lorsqu'il s'élance sur l'étroite
bande de bitume qui relie noirmoutier au
continent
trente athlètes de 18 pays pour un
parcours de plus de 4 km mais un
parcours contrarié par la montée des
eaux
un vrai moment de sport et d'émotions
d'angoise aussi avant le départ pour les
néophytes le thème de l'eau des coureurs
néophytes peut-être mais des spectateurs
eux pour certains chevronné avait l'air
d'être un peu un habitué des lieux
secrets mais je suis pas j'ai jamais
fait la course à l'autre bout d'ailés
saccades de cambronne à ces cinq lettres
là eric dubus recordman de france du 400
m en avait bien besoin car aux foulées
du bois plus on traîne et plus l'eau
monte et plus c'est dur ce n'est pas
pour rien qu'on appelle l'épreuve le
paris-roubaix de la course à pied sauf
qu'ici les vagues remplacent les pavés
même pour un champion il ya de quoi se
faire des frayeurs
j'ai eu peur quand même un moment donné
au milieu du bois
j'avais l'eau jusqu'aux genoux le lamari
qui arrivait très vite qu'on s'être
déporté j'avançais plus là je me suis
demandée emmené dans quelle galère je
suis la galère jean-paul game baril ne
connais pas cet international du burundi
en est à sa troisième participation
de quoi nourrir quelques ambitions
précises et c'est renier pascal
la première année c'est la première
année c'est la surprise de la deuxième
année c'est pour le chercher la guérilla
a fait plus que j'ai déjà participé des
approches des fois donc d'un projet mono
si pour gagner bah oui imaginez il a
essayé
il a même réussi avec les honneurs
depuis la construction du pont de
noirmoutier le wat seul passage à pied
sec avec le continent
vg tête un peu les foules et lui ont
donné une seconde vie et quelle vie boxe
avec un demi siècle après marcel cerdan
un titre mondial pour le français a cédé
cherifi poids moyens qui a remporté aux
points le combat contre l'américain
keith hall ces deux reprises pour le
français une réelle motivation et la
rage de vaincre
par ailleurs aucun championnat du monde
des lourds légers fabrice tiozzo a
finalement conservé son titre en battant
l'américain terry ray par arrêt de
l'arbitré à la première reprise
en championnat de france de rugby
colomiers le stade français sont les
deux derniers qualifiés pour les demi
finales hier après midi toulouse et
perpignan s'était déjà qualifiée les
demi-finales se joueront le 9 mai et
seront retransmises sur france
télévisions il incarnait la photographie
à l'envers le photographe surréaliste
man ray au grand palais près de 500
oeuvres pour cette rétrospective de
l'américain le plus français de
l'entre-deux-guerres man ray a signé
quelques photos les plus célèbres du
siècle georges bégoux bernard puceau en
1924 sur ce nu classique man ray rajoute
à la plume
les ouïes d'un violon et réalise la
photo / réaliste de la plus célèbre du
monde jeune peintre américain initié aux
fantaisies du dadaïsme par duchamp et
picabia man ray n'apprend la
photographic dans le but de reproduire
ses tableaux il peindra toute sa vie
mais c'est à la photo qu'il doit sa
notoriété
dans ce domaine il aura toutes les
audaces incompris aux états unis il sera
reconnu à paris où ses amis avaient
préparé son arrivée à leur façon on m'a
annoncé comme un millionnaire américain
qui arrivait à paris
le roi déchu ring en marchant des
charbons joue un jazz et tout ça dans
l'esprit d'anaïs naturellement
millionnaire il ne l'était pas mais il
ne deviendra grâce aux photos de mode
qu'ils réalisent en studio
n'hésitant pas à les retoucher man ray
n'est-il pas peindre avant tout
man ray le prince du recadrage d'un
terrain vague photographier dans sa
banalité en quatre coups de crayon
définissant un nouveau cadre il fait une
oeuvre d'art
on voit que l'élément utilisé dans
l'image est un élément extrêmement petit
un élément peut trés trés
partielle de l'image qui est dans le
tirage évidemment acquiert un velouté un
grain et qui tient à cette espèce de
volonté de se démarquer du réel au delà
de la technique la particularité de man
ray et de s'intéresser beaucoup pour
femmes il les saules ariz
parfois il leur donne un concours qui
leur confère la grâce d'un dessin d'inde
à moins qu'ils ne les transforme en
héroïne de saad
ces modèles sont souvent ses maîtresses
comme liminaire qu'il aime passionnément
et pour cause ton grand créateur
probablement un certain moment défini ce
que va être là la beauté de son époque
léonard de vinci le fait avec la joconde
manège avec l'olympia et l'hymne il a en
quelque sorte c'est là c'est le mona
lisa de magret vraiment une femme qui
magnétise est le regard des artistes les
plus les plus géniaux sur l'époque
quant à man ray pour en définir la
personnalité empruntant la formule a du
champ man ray nom masculin synonyme de
joie
jouer jouer avant de refermer ce journal
retournons à toulon pour le deuxième
tour de la législative partielle ou
apparemment se joue au coude à coude le
duel entre sandrine le chevalier et
odette casanova la socialiste et michaël
darmon
oui effectivement béatrice on assiste
ici depuis 25 minutes environ un match
très serré puisque il y à quelques
instants c'était donc sandrine chevalier
qui repassait en tête avec quelques voix
d'avancé
selon le dernier pointage effectué il ya
quelques minutes c'est odette casanova
qui obtiendrait 8825 voix contre 8729
pour sandrine chevalier tout se joue
dans les derniers bulletins
en ce moment on apprendrait que audi
casanova obtiendrait 51 18 % mais rien
est encore fait ça va se jouer à
quelques voix à quelques bulletins et
c'est dans ces minutes là pour l'instant
au de terra nova est encore en tête mais
très très légèrement
rendez vous donc dans l'édition de la
nuit ainsi se termine ce journal dans un
instant la météo présentée par nathalie
rihouet 21h votre signe de la soirée
magnum force avec clint eastwood demain
dans les 4 vérités à 7h50 françoise
laborde recevra alain krivine demain
soir à 20h vous retrouverez daniel
bilalian merci de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2